for the first time in almost 450 days
right now this morning there are no
government mandated rules for southern
nevada that means in most cases
no masks no social distancing hector
mejia live this morning in downtown las
vegas
where the changes sparked just a bit of
a big celebration hector good morning to
you
good morning and it's sort of more on
the quiet side right now these
barricades right next to me are left
over from the party last night and clark
county's coronavirus restrictions
officially expired at midnight that
means no more caps on capacity no more
social distancing
and no more masks required we were live
here you know the party's still going
right behind us
but we were here live back on june 4th
when casinos were allowed to reopen and
the feeling this morning was
very similar to that there was a big
celebration on fremont street here in
downtown led by a video message for
mayor
carolyn goodman and a special display on
the viva vision
canopy live bands took to the stage for
the first time in over a year in front
of a video board with the message
downtown rocks again
most visitors were ready to party and
some would still like to see
some rules stay in effect
i guess with how packed it is normally i
don't think it's going to be much of a
difference here
so i mean i guess it's whatever i just
wish that they would still implement
people wearing masks like that's the
biggest thing
individual businesses can still ask you
to wear a mask or socially distance if
they choose
though practically all of fremont street
and the las vegas strip have
opted to drop those requirements a lot
of people are excited for the changes
that things are reopening and things
getting seemingly back to normal
of course this all depends on the covet
19 numbers
and if we see spikes the governor or
clark county could step
in and bring back those restrictions all
over again solutions hope that doesn't
happen
reporting live on fremont street hector
mejia 8 news now